so cover crops basically they provide a
source of food for the animals as well
but what you would do is you would plant
those perhaps in late summer early fall
so to speak in your garden and just
direct so and so some of the great cover
crops are like peas oh there's something
called hairy vet and there's so many
more but what happens is like peas
especially which are one of my favorites
and so are oats they fix nitrogen from
the atmosphere and add it back into the
soil and as you know some the fruiting
plants like tomatoes and cucumbers they
love a nitrogen rich soil so what you
would do is grow those and just randomly
broadcast sprinkle which is just
basically throw the seeds in the soil
cover it up with a little bit more soil
Let It Grow and once it grows a couple
of inches tall you can just chop and
drop which is cut them and let them lie
flat while the roots inside provide the
nitrogen the green masses on top going
to insulate the soil